today's guest is a two-time
kentucky derby winner and he's um
and he's also won the preakness if you
familiar with horse racing and
outdoor horsing and this man is a
special man he's from
uh veracruz mexico
and uh really excited to learn all about
jockeying i've always wanted to know
about it
you know what i'm saying who's in that
cockpit of that horse
today's guest is mr mario
[Music]
gutierrez
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
mario gutierrez man so what happened man
you got you had you had some uh what
happened yesterday you said something
happened
wow i was riding a cable thing my car
broke down yesterday so i took it to the
dealership
on the interstate or on a on a side road
no i was in the
in the freezer yeah that's always a real
rodeo bro when you break down out there
it was a brand new car too so i don't
know what happened
uh yeah i had to take it to the
dealership and then uh
get a loaner car and this morning i had
to go to the track to
like you know do the training the usual
training that i had to do before racing
okay uh i was doing that i was getting
ready to leave grab a couple of things
to
show you guys and then um as i was
getting out of the racetrack freaking
car power
went off the same thing happened the
loaner car broke down too
long so my age i called my agent right
away and then he
he loaned me his car and he's like get
out of here yeah
and so when you go uh and let's put it
what brand of car is it man let's get
this brand out there they need to oh i
don't even want to say it
you don't is it it's a fancy car
actually it is it is
bmw maybe no up up yeah oh range rover
and then that area is like a maserati it
was a wow
yeah it's a maserati yeah you drive a
maserati well no that was a laundry car
i i drive an alpha
alpha right now oh that's what nick
drives and then uh
uh the engine light went on the cars
that's what happened
like i was driving and then the power
went out like it was like probably a
bicycle could have gone faster than that
so
and when the power goes in your car do
you kind of get that same feeling
actually i do like when i do it like
come on come on just one more boy you
have to do it
oh i did i did that actually i did i did
it i couldn't see that it's almost like
a habit huh yeah
yeah i was like even when i watch my
replays when i like after like um
the race finished and i come back to the
yorkshire man if i win or finish at
close second i'm watching the replay and
all those times
as i'm getting to the white on the ribs
i'm like leaning towards like thinking
that something different is gonna happen
just a habit oh just a habit that's
interesting man um
and so you're uh whenever you said like
today you went to or yesterday or today
you went to do the training like what is
that like so you go there
is there a time you have to be there on
a race day so today's a race day yeah
today's a race day well typically
even in a race day we uh monday to
through
what seven days monday through sunday we
uh train horses okay you know in those
courses that we we
training um we usually get to run them
like you know
a week from now like or 15 days from now
so we're constantly
working these horses and then like
they're not necessarily gonna run on the
weekend you know but they might run like
the week the weekend after you know so i
see so horses that are gonna be like say
if i'm going to go to the racetrack
like maybe in a week or two the horses
i'm seeing going to see then
you guys are kind of training them
getting them used to the crack no
getting ready no
choose like a like a normal athlete you
know getting the physical training
into it you know the loan capacity so
they're able to push harder in the
stretch and things like that it's like
it's okay you guys get them out there
like athletes and what time do you guys
do that kind of these days
it was early in the morning the race
track opened around like i think 4 30
you know and then it closes at like 10
o'clock
i usually get that at 6 30 you know
that's when i start and
usually by 9 9 45 i'm done wow
yeah so dude you're on the horse and
it's going fast huh yeah
is it scary or no no it's not scary for
me
anymore you know it was a little bit
scary when i i started
uh when i was young but now it's like
you know like any
other racing um athlete i guess you know
like you just get used to your love for
that
i love what i do so i'm like i live for
that you know it's like that journaling
is the excitement and it's
like all of that who's the athlete are
you the athlete or the horse is the
athlete or you're both the athlete we're
both
you know like it's almost like it's but
no it's not almost like he's a team you
know like he isn't
the athlete you know he usually he
actually does most of the work you know
the hard work you know yeah
we are at least two because we need to
constantly be uh
fit enough to to ride these horses like
have our weight
you know uh um checked you know we
checked you know there's certain way
that we
we can pass you know so that's what like
fig
physically we have to be super fit
because these are like 1000
pound animals that we need to control
and we need to you know like um
be able to manage oh yeah high speed
um when you uh when you
so like on a race day what will your day
be like on that day
it's usually so like later today when
you go in for the race like what is it
like when you get there like how did you
go through like what is kind of the
the typical typical yeah well for me
it's like you know like i i
um i wake up like i said i go to morning
training
and then i usually finish like like i
say 10 o'clock you're done you know
okay and when you're training these
horses like what are you doing you're
like just almost like
like acting at a race almost yeah yeah
it's exactly that it's just like
we simulate a a little race by
themselves you know it's just like you
know each horse you know
it's not like we're working on tango
force at the same time not like a race
but like
for example uh uh i'll work my horse
five furless you know that means that i
had to make five furlongs in a certain
amount of time like 101 the trainer will
tell you how much
how fast you want him you he wants him
he wants you to train the horse okay you
know so he if he tells you hey i want
you to work
five four loans and one on one so you um
you
do your best to pass those five four
notes in one minute and one
second so um so you're out there just
kind of setting goals almost like a
uh like like somebody on a track team
yeah yeah
that's exactly that you know and that
that gives like the horse fitness and
the long capacity for like do they like
it do the horses like being racers
yeah it's like a any normal
uh well any living kitchen you know
there are some horses that don't you
know there's some horses that like you
know that
no matter how much you ask them they
will they choose no born to do that you
know but they're like oh yeah like
antonio brown
and there are some horses they they do
really love you know they're like uh
it's maybe like uh i can't explain that
because it's a feeling you know
sometimes i'm on top of them and i do
the burn minimum and i just encourage
them to go a little faster and they are
waiting for that
oh they're wonderful yeah they want it
yeah so some of them can you tell
sometimes how
excited they are about it and how much
they like it yeah oh you can yeah well
yeah i i'm i'm i feel lucky because i i
feel that i can tell that you know
because
i grew up some with horses since early
very early age so
and uh so yeah so what was that like so
i'm trying to think of what else i would
think about like being out there
and then okay so then you get there for
the race day now on the race day
on on the race you guys show up and
what happens like do you have to be drug
tested do the
horse have to be drug tested yeah horses
get drug tests we don't
we don't we do get drug tax drug tests
too but that's
like uh it's coming like like a lottery
you know the officials go there and
like they will just speak randomly you
know whoever you're going to get this
okay put out whatever they want do you
want to get tests and then
you have to go and then get this do some
people
use is there any like performance
enhancing drugs for the riders
is anybody out there like some some guys
can be high and do it or do whatever
no no no no we are like truly like as
any other athlete and this like if
there is not not um if we
are in a perky set or something that we
need to have a prescription if if
you don't if all of a sudden you get
tests and then you pop for a pill like
you know like an org or something like
that then you get you get suspended or
damn really oh yeah so everybody got to
really keep it together the horse and
the people huh yeah
so it sounds like a lot of jockeys have
prescriptions
yeah exactly right
so what is the fitness of it like for
you
fitness i for us because we have to be
more lean
and stronger but as strong as like a 120
pounder can get
you know so right yes i'm from louisiana
originally they have a lot of guys from
louisiana that are jockeys yeah
yeah there's a lot of like uh we have
like alvarado like you there's a couple
of names you would hear milan's song
like a lot of names you would hear a lot
of i think he's a whole famous
horse racing industry he's from there i
think yeah is he what's his name candice
normal
uh what's the last name the letter that
starts with the
doorman d-o-r-m-o-n-d no d-e
d-e
the long no
can we skate my english is horrible so
it's not my second language so like
don't
mind bad it's my first language yeah
that one the first one
oh that's a hard name for english people
yeah
ken ken desormo where's he out of
louisiana
a lot of guys they got a little those
little swamp babies man a lot of french
little swamp babies they pull them up
from maurice louisiana yeah that's that
is a real swamp town right there
and so it's popular in that area is it
are there a lot of are you mexican or
which
mexican both your parents are mexican
yeah my parents so or is there a lot of
mexican jockeys as well
oh yeah yeah really a lot of jokes a lot
of
latin latino jokes a lot of panamanians
puerto ricans um yeah so yes because
it's interesting that a lot of those
guys are from louisiana and then
a lot of them are from mexico why
because it's smaller stature
i think so but there is really jockeys
all over the place we have like
italian jockeys here right now we have a
french jockeys you know
i think it's like whoever is small
enough to be a child
so it's more about a size thing that
really it doesn't matter kind of where
people are from
yeah what um what was your journey in a
jock in like how did it kind of start
out for you
because it's such a unique i mean i was
talking a friend of mine the other day
uh this guy walker walker bueller he
plays for
the dodgers actually and he was on here
a while back and
he and i went to dinner the other night
and he's telling me about he had a
brother-in-law
who was a um jockey and robbie albarado
is the guy's name
and so he went uh so i was like maybe we
should get a jockey to come on the
podcast and talk
and then you and nick spoke and um and
so yeah man it's just fascinating to
think uh
to think of what that life is like and
what it and and who even does it like
so take me again a little bit more like
your fitness and your size and your
weight what do you have to
stay at i probably if you i had to stay
like under like 117 118 117 you know
that in case that i have to
reduce i don't have to reduce too much
you know like if i have to ride horses
which is like 118 i only had to pull up
two
pounds the day of the race you know
something like that you know i tried to
manage that
like really well uh do they weigh you
before the race yeah each race before
each race they weigh you in
yeah and if you're over can the trainer
the owner say
we're gonna get someone else uh i think
we're only allowed to be
you have to if i'm gonna be if i think
i'm not gonna make that weight i had to
report it like an
hour earlier okay that before the uh
before the first race
so if i already know that hey i can make
that whip i'm going to be one point over
i have to if i don't do that then yeah
we get penalized
or i think yeah the in the trainer is
allowed to say well i don't
i need to replace my jockey so on the
race day that's usually the same jockeys
like on a scheduled day of races
at like um say it like um
santa anita right santa ana what is this
santonita santanita right
so on a scheduled day of races there may
be like 10 races or something for the
day
yeah today or 11. wow so you're going to
race 11 times
no no i only ride four horses four races
and is it every other race how do they
put you guys in there it depends
is it very complicated right because
like that is uh
in the racing office they decide what
race goes first what's good second so
it's like depends if uh
you know depends where where i land you
know i can ride the first four
but then not necessarily like or i can
run the first the third
six seven so do you ride for a specific
trainer do you ride on a specific horse
like
how does who does the jockey work for
i'm
i'm very lucky that i write for a
specific owner
okay yeah uh you ride only on his horses
i ride most
all of his horses i right okay all of
them and i that has been since 2012.
i'm very very lucky so and a very very
sweet position that that
that way um so i'm not specifically for
the same trainer for the
owner you know so uh so that's that's
that's good for
me yeah he has so you have more like
that
that means you just have like more of a
long-term or you just have
uh work what's it called net
work if you have the same job at a long
time a tenure
yeah or yeah you just have like some
assurance you're more assured like you
have a contract kind of
it's like it's not like a real contract
it's more like a spoken country you know
like a
like a french like he's been so loyal to
me and i've been loyal to him so like
it's just like a a
partnership partnership that is going to
continue we had early success in
2012 i think that's what yeah yeah some
job security yeah yeah
so uh so then so when you get on the
horse you're on the horse and you take
the horse out to the
what to the racetrack to like the voting
booth that i'm talking about like oh the
paddock
that we call it the paddle the paddock
is the circle this is the little circle
where like you know the horses run
uh before we get on top of the horses
they like you know there's like
the people can look at them you know uh
if you're gonna bet you're like the
gamblers
you're gonna look and see which horse
you like and you can look at them then
then uh the trainers like put like put
us on the horse and then we
we go to the racetrack and do the
warm-up the pre-warm-up before the
before the race okay so if i'm a better
right
which nick is but if i'm a better and i
go out to the paddock is there anything
i can look for
as a batter that can give me any sort of
insight as to how the
the only thing that i can that i can
that i can that i can give you and
a tip sort of you know try to look for
horses they're not too nervous or sweaty
you know because they usually are like
they're not gonna perform well like most
of those horses are like you know
they're
too nervous and so sweaty they already
um
spending a lot of energy you know being
being like so
a sweaty horse dude
besides that i'm horrible my wife told
me like
never to say to give her any tips about
horse racing because
she always loses no she likes it better
now she does once in a while be like oh
my god i'm training this course that i
really really like you know you should
put some
some money on them you know and then uh
the horse will run
third or fourth and then you'll be like
i don't want no more of your tips
um so you get out there you go out for
the warm-up and the warm-up is what it's
just kind of like a little trot or it's
like
chuck or gallop you know try to like get
the get the floor going
on the horses you know and then um try
to warm up everything you know before
like because now they're
when it's time to raise you're gonna
you're gonna ask them to do their best
you know
yeah and can a horse stretch can you
tell a horse to stretch or they just
stretch if they want to
you can stretch the horses you can like
there's like you can you can do
they they have chiropractors they have
massage syrup as the horses
really yeah yeah dude what kind of
pervert would stand here and just
massage a horse lego i don't know
you had to you had to one
can you imagine just standing there all
day
and trying not to get an erection that
would be the hardest thing i feel like
even if you were straight male and
you're you and the horses straight i
think it would just be so
hard not to how uh
how strong are these animals they can be
pretty strong their horses there can be
like
so nice you know in terms of like you
can like uh
pretty much do anything with them like
uh they obey
you know like you can one hand you can
maneuver you know and there are some
horses there like you
two hands all you weigh all you can pull
and there's still like
no listening to you so it's tricky you
know
just like people i guess huh yeah yeah
they are like people are so smart
do they feel like do horses seem like
people like the more time you spin
around horses do they seem like people
do they seem like
is there another animal that you kind of
relate them to
do you feel like you actually can have
like a connection with the horse
what is it like because i've always been
a little bit probably afraid of horses i
guess
because we never went around any horses
growing up you know like we would see
some but
and like feed them apples and stuff
through the fence but
i never like spent time around them you
know oh horses
are super smart i think that's yeah like
the more time you spend with with a
horse you know the more you get to know
them and the more you establish a
connection and then like
once you establish a connection it's
like it's like having a dog you know you
love that animal
it's just like it's a strong bone that
you that you that you
that you have with this horse you know
so yeah at like time the more time you
spend with
with the horses is like it's hard not to
love really fall in love with them yeah
just like a dog shoes like a dog yeah
yeah
and they're very therapeutic because you
can like my wife has a pony that we can
use it to trail right you know and then
like if you're having a bad day
you know or when when i'm having a bad
day or like i have too many
too much thinking on my head i go i saw
him i take him to the trolls in the
mountains in altadena
and it's just so terpeuric is just like
so
cool and relaxing i should live on one
of those
i should be tied around one of those i
need some therapy
i need some therapy man um so
you get out there you back to the race
you get then you get in the cage right
or
actually we had a question that came in
right here from a uh
from a user for you right here not a
user look i'm not judging the guy
he does look like baby yeah he's been up
a little late
but uh it also looks like john cusack's
brother
what's up mario quick question are there
jockey groupies like chicks that travel
around so when you win the kentucky
derby you're
golden for a couple weeks yeah what's
that like are there kind of like uh
[Music]
did you meet your wife through the races
some
i did uh yes i did my
my uh my i met my wife because uh my
father-in-law at the time when i
i i went to canada i met my wife in
canada oh she's canadian yes she's
coming
canadians are awesome yeah so um
her dad used to own some horses um
and that's how true i met her family
first
and she she was studying in victoria
canada so i didn't met her until like
two years after that after i was in
canada oh so the family already liked
you oh yeah
they love me they still don't they love
me more than they'll
they let you ride their horse
um but yeah i think uh to the question
yeah i think they in
any sports i think that any sport has
like some groupies
i think so yeah yeah that's cool um
what type of like who are the owners
these days like a lot of times when i
think of horse owners i think of like a
rich old white guy kind of
is that still kind of the and no
judgment against it but is that still
like
the type of person that owns horses do
you
like or is there all types yeah i think
of this guy whoever this guy is and i
don't even
we don't know who this guy is but that's
who we think of
is this does this look like every owner
kind of or is it all types of people
it's all type of like what they
basically whoever wants a like
they have money right i have a lot of
money okay so it's someone that has
expendable income they can get away yes
so like
i don't think necessarily has to be
white but it needs
it needs to have some cash so they need
to have some cash yeah do they ever have
groups out there where you
whether you feel like it's a um like
it's a setup like they have like a shady
owner or it seems like a little weird
like
like that like maybe they're just trying
to drug a horse and get it through does
that ever happen
or did it used to happen do you ever
notice anything like that
well i i don't like i i don't that i
don't know
specifically specifically no you know
like uh i
said it again you know because like like
like a group or like
like i guess do you ever see like is
there ever like um
like a owner trainer kind of a
a team a team oh a team they try to do
that edition yeah often and it's just
like and maybe
you've seen them over the years and
they've come and gone or whatever but is
there ever is there a lot of that going
on or is stuff pretty rare like is it
maybe back in the days will happen a lot
and no not in racetracks like
like like santanita that will that would
be considered like a like
like a in
um i will be con something that will be
considered like you know like one of the
top right strikes santanita new york
kentucky you know like and
there's a prestigious you know like like
an elite or like an a racetrack right
like an a race track and then you you
have b
racetrack c race tracks you know and
that probably probably will cure more
into like
like small racetrack where there is not
a lot of your restriction or no not a
lot of people watching
like i wouldn't be surprised if that
those type of things happen there oh it
gets a little more seedy or the way yeah
yeah
yeah the further you go yeah maybe like
for example like ufc i watch a lot of
fights you know like say ufc now
is you sat and everything is like
cracking down and things like that but
the more you go to the lesser
organization well
maybe they're not as tight you know so
oh the urine you could drink it i feel
like off
these guys you know what i'm saying i'd
had a glass whatever anderson silva had
into my thing
i mean they just had yeah it's
definitely a lot cleaner these days yeah
um who are some of the fighters you like
oh i like a bunch
you do like the nick bro yeah yeah
crazy love yeah um i wish nick fought
more man
i know i don't know what's up with him i
wish i wish to i i i
i just don't want him to get older and
then wish he had fought more
when he was younger you know but you
never know with those guys right he they
they really seem so genuine you know
that like
the way i look at him i don't think that
will occur to him you know
yeah that's a good point he loves like
you know he does what he wants
it seems like so i think they definitely
do what they want
yeah did you see that fight the other
night with edwards yeah that was good
huh yeah
oh come on go for the kill he's just
pointing at him he's pointing at him and
i'm like my wife is yelling
i'm jelly my son is looking at us like
what the heck is going on with you guys
yeah and i was jealous
yeah that was magical man yeah what do
you think about the uh did you see the
last fourier
mcgregor fight yeah i was surprised i
was surprised that uh
how fairly easy uh pourier beat mcgregor
yeah i think mcgregor beats him this
time you think so i think so
i feel like it's uh i i mean i
definitely don't think that
but i think it's hard i i just think
it's hard to like
get that mentality you know oh but
unless he doesn't have that anymore you
know i i will blame the first
the first fight until like you know he's
like you know long time
hasn't fight you know and then like
that's that's what i think you know but
and the i will relate it again to horses
there is some horses the
you know the very good horses that are
undefeated
like they can win one two three four
five races in a row
and the moment they touch the feet the
moment somebody some other horse pass
them
they're never the same really yeah so
that thing happens to fighters too you
know the more
you know they feel this thing and all of
a sudden they you know two three losses
and yeah like
mess up with their hands happens to
comedians too man happened to me
but no that's so interesting so you
there's there can be like a moment that
happened in a race like in a big race
where another horse passes it
and it's never the same yeah yeah for
horses that happen it happened to me it
happened to a very good horse that i had
really yeah which one was it what was
nyquist 2016 kentucky derby winner
right and so that's the and so let's see
yes so take me back to like
i mean you had just started racing
right you've been racing and or you just
been racing in where in california for a
year
not even you won no no no i mean
i mean my first kentucky i was lucky
enough to get my first kentucky that'd
be back in 2012.
and then i was racing in canada okay on
the races the racing the racing season
finish in um
september october so uh usually i will
come down to san francisco and ride
in san francisco in the winter and then
but for whatever reason uh
they didn't want to give stalls to my
this my canadian stable that i was with
at the time okay
so they reached out to santanita and
santanita was like yeah we'll give you
some
um some stables so you can you can run
here your horses so
that's how i ended up in l.a you know in
santa anita in
late 2011. so that was your first time
getting to los angeles
yeah and then that was like yeah october
november december january and in four
months then i was
i was uh i got introduced to to to i'll
have another which
went in and won the kentucky there yeah
yeah you won twice right
he won the kentucky and then he won the
preakness yeah but you won
i want yeah i won 2011 2012 and then
2016.
so was there like uh is there like a
rookie year
for writers yeah yeah apprentice we
called
we are called apprentice when we are our
first year
when they we get the license to be a
professional writer then our first year
we call apprentice
and then with that does we are allowed
to raise
10 pounds lighter than the professional
joking
so if a professional jockey is what 118
118 then you get you're allowed to run
your horse with one weight
you know you could ride on 108 yeah i
can't know anymore
i used to yeah i didn't even chew gum
i'd be like yeah no i i can't anymore i
used to when i was 18 years old
yeah oh so what phases what phases a
jockey out of the job
well i i think that's like fighters you
know like you're um
your body will tell you or or
unfortunate or an accident an
unfortunate accident that can
end your career at any moment does that
happen something i mean
yeah a little m shyamalan does it uh
and does it happen does that happen
sorry i have so many questions right now
it's okay
um okay cool so uh does that
yeah take me some through some of the
dangers what is some of that danger like
if you have a
like is it like a like uh how can you
get hurt how can you get
i mean you can get thrown off of the
horse that's probably the biggest fear
yeah that's probably the biggest fear uh
uh
the biggest fear for me is probably like
getting getting turned off
of a horse if i'm like in the in the
first and
the four front runners because then you
have you know for sure you have people
coming behind you you know and
like i say these are like 12 200 pound
animals and
bad drivers yeah you don't want you
don't want none of them to
catch you mid air or like on the floor
so that's probably
so that's almost one of the scary parts
i bet about taking the lead is that it's
somewhere in your head you're like
now if something bad happens all these
horses are going to come up behind you
yeah but you don't think i think like
the moment
you start you had those thoughts that's
probably a good
a good time to retire oh yeah if you're
like going in the front and you're
thinking about oh my god you know like
you have a problem
yeah no you should be focusing on on how
to win the race yeah i think the moment
you start having those type of thoughts
i think you should call it quits
that would be me i'd be like you guys go
on ahead
uh how ex how okay so you get into the
paddock you get or you get into the gate
right is that after the warm up yeah
they gave that so after the warm-up you
guys
because yeah i'm always wondering
whenever i'm there betting or whatever
i'm like jesus what are you thanks for
everyone else
yeah they got one guy and then the guy
in the pink hat comes out i'm like why
is the guy wearing a thing i don't even
know what's going on i feel like it's a
gender reveal
but then finally they get everybody
lined up
is it easier to be the first horse that
gets lined up in there or the last horse
or does it even matter
yeah i think it does matter i i
particularly would like to
like um loan last but you don't always
but we don't choose that it's like it's
like whoever number you have is by
number so whoever is like you know if
you have it
seven eight nine ten you know they're
you're probably gonna be
um put on the gate last right so i
prefer that you know because then my
horse doesn't have
too much time to think inside the gate
it's just basically
go ready go yeah and so once your horse
is in the gate what are you doing
in there like um i see you you brought a
is this a saddle yes a saddle yeah
that's what we use to ride them can i
pick it up yeah
you can pick it up dang dude
this is the lingerie of saddles huh
my god japanese saddle is it yeah
wow shout out to japan yeah shout out to
japan dude
very ironic that they are have a driving
instrument
that they put together no shade but
that's wild
so how does this even i know right
i think i'd just rather wear a thick
underpants i'm like this is so
small so this goes towards the front of
the horse
and you uh and what is this what is it
this is
yeah no oh my gosh
and this is yours mg right here amg yeah
oh that's cool man
um so and this is
about is this is a pretty commonplace
uh saddle yeah that will probably like
most of yeah
unless you go like there is a little bit
bigger saddles and they actually
weigh smaller saddles they should
probably like mid size
at all you know there is like there is
some saddles that are probably like way
one pound
for like people like joke is the
struggle a lot with weight
oh really they're basically two stirrups
and
and then that little tiny thing
honestly like it probably is like this
big
some chubby jockey yeah
like okay and so this hooks into the
belts that go that girl yeah yeah like
you should be like
like um like elastic band you know we
call them girts you know that
that's right okay so you're out there
you get on this you have the saddle
you're on the horse
and you're in the gate and then what
happens what are you doing while you're
in the gate to keep the horse ready to
race we just try to
to um uh your best and to like just have
a you we have another person that is
kind of like helping you manage a horde
while you're in the gate and this
happens
more than maybe like 15 seconds during
the game you know 20 seconds 25 seconds
the most you know so for that
time you have a person kind of helping
you control the horse and kind of like
make sure he's looking forward just like
a rodeo almost like a rodeo when they're
getting on the ball something like that
you know and then um
hold on and wait till wait till the
they get open and then it's good time
liquid death you know the summer gets
the most out of you
physically it drains you it'll suck the
water it'll purge it
get it out of your skin out of your body
out of your arms and legs it'll get you
that's why babel is the number one
selling
language learning app
from ordering in restaurants or asking
for directions
babble will help if you don't know how
to talk
and you ask for direction someone's not
going to know what you want
you might ask for direction you might be
there your house could be on fire and
they're going to hand you a hat or a
you know a fork you don't know you have
to be able to communicate
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language
on the go like spanish wish i knew more
so i could talk to mario today in
spanish
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages
including spanish french italian and
german
that's right learn a language damn it
i'm just going to ask you point blank
right now when you purchase a
three-month
babel subscription you get into an
additional three months for free
that's six months that's six months of
babbling for the price of this three
go to babel babbel.com
and use promo code theo for an extra
three months free
that's right learn el langua
go to babel babbel.com
code theo for an extra three months
free keeps is what i've been using
to keep my hair you know i got hair
and i got time on this earth and those
are things that usually don't coincide
so i'm trying to keep what i have keep
that carpet
on my head keeps helps men
keep their hair and prevent hair loss
now if you're already entirely bald then
keeps is
not the right solution nope it can't
reverse
what's going on but it can help you keep
what you have
that's why i use it look at my head it's
not bad two out of three men
will experience some form of hair loss
by the time they're 35. yep you got to
fight back
it's low-cost treatments start at just
10 per month and keeps offers
generic versions are generic
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash theo to receive your first
month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
theo to get your first month free
keeps.com
theo and so once the gate opens what is
the first thing you does the horse
automatically know to go
yeah they know to go and then sometimes
you have to encourage them you know
and then whoever the plan whoever
whatever the plan was with the with the
trainer whatever the trainer told you
like hey i want you to be in the front i
want you to be
you know mid-pack you know let two three
horses go
i want you to be last you know then
right away then you try to
to to to do the best you can to stick to
the plan
wow is that the most what's the most
exciting point in the race if there is
like is it right when that gate opens is
that frenetic it feels like it would be
so like
there's so many things happening at once
is it hard to kind of just
stay in in what's going on with you yeah
the most definitely the game because
it's like like an f1
race racing you know like the start
right everybody
you want to get your position as soon as
as soon as you can you know and then
from that point on so uh uh then then
you're able to like
chill relax save your horse or like you
know
those type of things you know so the
star is definitely
like very crucial and very excited but
like a lot of adrenaline a lot of rush
going on
to me that part and then you know like
um
like the last quarter of a mile of the
race you know especially if i know oh i
still have a ladder i still have
something
i still have a lot in the tank you know
that's that's probably the most excited
how do you know if you have a lot in the
tank is it because you've previously
tried that horse and got an idea of
what's in that horse or is it because
in that moment you can kind of tell
what's in the tank
bush you know like it's because like you
get to know the horse prior you know on
training
and i consider myself lucky you know
because like i can tell
if i choose holding my range you know
like
being and been and seeing we've been in
and and
and um how do you say that's like
synchronized or being
oh yeah in a mutual female volleyball
squad yeah
i feel you but yeah i know you see it's
like synchronicity kind of yeah
so i and uh all that you know like um
i get to feel my horse you know you feel
the energy like it's they have a lot and
horses have a lot of energy so you feel
them you know so like jus
they'll tell you well uh if if they're
tired or that's that's okay you know
what
that's all i got buddy you know i have
you you can tell when the horse give you
everything or you can tell when your
horse is like no no we have something
you know there is little tricks
that you can do mid-race to kind of test
how much horse
you have left you know okay what are
some of those take me through some of
those like just even small little things
small little things he's like for
example you know you don't you're um
you're like comfortable holding him you
know he's obeying what you're saying and
all of a sudden you kind of go like
and did it it's just like you feel the
push the the
the kind of shifting gears in the car
you feel that okay i have it so you can
like you ease up on him and be like okay
don't worry i see what's up maybe we're
gonna do it
we need to do it yeah yeah okay then
sometimes you're asking the horse and it
goes nowhere and then he's like oh
it's going to be a rough trip he's like
looking at the concession
basically yeah um is there a way to
to turn around say a horse kind of feels
like it's not into it or it's gassed out
or it's not having that
flare in that race is there a way to uh
recalibrate that kind of horse or or is
it just kind of like sometimes that's
just the way that
that it rolls well they're like
horses right it's a living creature so
like no like in that and that is nothing
you can do in me
or to to to shift that you know when a
horse can give you
all the air when when a fire is tired
there's no way you can pump air into him
and all of a sudden
wouldn't it be great if they brought a
pump out right so i know like basically
you
i mean it's our responsibility just kind
of like wrap up you know
save him you know and right save him so
then you're thinking about a chance for
him to run a few weeks from now yeah
yeah you know
regroup you know like maybe he wasn't
feeling good that day you know that's
the other thing you know you can be on
the favorite but what if that horse
that specific day that is going to run
is she's not feeling it you know like oh
he is
about to get sick you know you know
sometimes when we are about to get a
cold
you know like you can feel it you know
two three days before that you kind of
feel a little bit
yeah yeah so the same thing with horses
you know so
huh wow that's so interesting man we got
a question that came right here for you
mario
yo mr gutierrez
got a question for you big dog
what is it like straddling
one of those land sharks with
millions of people watching you how do
you
stay composed and not absorb the
pressure
that is being a jockey in the kentucky
derby
yeah are there races like the kentucky
derby thank you brother gang baby
are there races like that kentucky derby
where it's
that this you just feel the energy so
much bigger yeah
yeah i think i think the kentucky derby
should be on your bucket list you know
choose to go and experience like 160 000
people you know
all eyes looking and like the 20 horses
that are competing there
they build up to the kentucky derby is
like it's a different base
so take me through can we see your uh
race when the the the uh
your first win there and would you say
it was 2016 2012
and how many times have you watched this
a lot you know no many no
no no very many times yeah i haven't
re-watched it no
[Applause]
larry komas with the call okay so where
are you at in this world
and as expected trinity berg had a great
start
gemologist okay so let's stop uh when we
get to that between horses and
bodemeister is done on the inside
again ahead of pretty bird bodhi meister
in trinidad
so we can see that while where it's like
the flock
okay right here so what's kind of going
on right here like
horses are coming out some of them i
guess
like are some of the like some of the
riders are in the lead here like
yeah is that because the the the jockey
has like
kind of commanded them to be in the lead
or did the horse just come out strong
no a lot of horses are like being
command to go to the lead you know and
everybody is trying to be
um it's like not necessarily that you
want to go to the lead but you
want to get a clear path so you can be
like maybe like to be in front of
a horse whatever horse is behind you
because that way
you can get your position faster you
know
okay and now if a horse comes say you
you come out of the gate
and another horse kind of gets in front
of you a little bit is that bad for your
horse
yeah because then you had to you had to
regroup you have to you have to check
your horse now you have to weigh
whatever that
that horse in front of you is going to
do and then you hop in there
after that then you get to do you know
your your strategy or basically choose
plan b or plan z you know now you're
there now just what you do you know you
chose to stay there
or you chose to go around that horse in
front of you it's just a lot of like you
have to adjust in
the moment is there a moment there's a
horse here that's in the back and he's
only in the back by about three lengths
it looks like
and uh is that right you think how many
links has he been in the back
yeah he's probably like around six seven
likes people okay so
my length math is what it used to be i
was just trying to sound like i knew
what i was saying but
so he's about six or seven links back
yeah he is does that horse
he still has a chance to win though huh
of course yeah no of course he has
unless that horse uh uh um
um strategy or or or um
was to go into the front oh you know the
front if that wasn't if that was the
case then he's totally screwed
he's like not liking his chances and the
jockey's realizing at that point
this is probably just not going to be
going to be good yeah okay
okay cool let's let's keep it cruising
then start gemologist is also out and
where are you at right here
on the outside oh there you are cruising
huh yeah and now bodhi meister's ahead
of trinity
you're kind of in the middle right now
right now yeah the purple helmet i'm in
the middle
i'm gonna
so you have turns here like how much
turns do you have two
two turns so you have this one and then
coming out this one yeah
now what do you do during the turns man
well you tried to save as many turns
yeah yeah because you can't do much like
even if you're playing a racing game or
something like on the turn you're like
slow down a little bit yeah you just
have to like be in the turn there's not
you can't i feel like it's hard to use
strategy
yeah no you have to you just have to
help the horse to take the turn the best
way possible you know and then like
set up your uh uh um coming
out of out of this first round because
you're gonna get a stretch again you
know
okay and then line up to get the second
the last turn you know
okay okay let's keep it cruising here
will take charge indy as they move into
the turn and then it's daddy knows best
on the far outside liaison creative
cause optimizer along the rail
now do you feel like you had a chance in
this race right here what were you
feeling like
i did that i have a chance because this
is a horse that i like i was i was
i got very familiar with him before
going to the kentucky derby and you have
to understand like this never happened
to me
they now happens to nobody all of a
sudden like a kid coming from a
sea racetrack or d racetrack you know
like uh and all of a sudden you know he
isn't the kentucky there but first of
all it was a lot of doubts it's like you
know like
well is he even have it you know is it
really that can he be good enough to
be in this that's right does he even
have his adult teeth i'm sure a lot of
people are wondering you know
yeah oh they're probably thinking oh
he's totally going to melt down you know
or things like that all right the
pressure and all these things
was there a lot of pressure no no i'm
very lucky that i don't the pressure
i i'm very good under pressure you know
and
i couldn't i couldn't like commute in
near and forth right here
yeah i'm for right now so this is the
second turn six seconds
wow i thought i was gonna finish second
because if you see that horse in the in
front
okay he is like super super in front of
me oh totally
and then but my course still has some
guys so i'm thinking like oh my god you
know i'm gonna finish second in the
kentucky that way i was
i was stopping right here right here
okay
what do you do on the horse here so you
have now we also have i just want to
show this here this is called a what
whip crop okay whip or crop and then
we have your helmet here okay and so
that's pretty light
everybody wears kind of the same type of
helmet yeah okay do you
now at this point how much times can you
whip the horse as much as you want
this yeah but
a lot of rules have changed now now
we're we're not allowed you know
but i i'm never like uh um
known to him accords a lot you know so
if you see here like i hit once and then
you push your horse you know you had to
give him a chance to respond you know
but um but uh back in 2012 there wasn't
like uh
a restriction on how many times you can
whip a horse it was like a step dad out
there
if you want yeah you could have gone
like tata like you know but
does the horse does it hurt the horse
much it doesn't did what do you think
well it depends i think back in the days
it used to if i if i show you one of the
the the the um whips that they used to
use the the
old-timers you know that's right really
they used to use some seriousness yeah
yeah that's interesting it's not as like
i mean if this were lead it would be
tough oh yeah yeah yeah
okay so here we go let's go through this
man this is crazy so what is your
strategy right here like do you have any
no no that does it like as soon as you
go to the last
stretch like that's just like try to go
as fast like
try to ask your horse to finish like
yelling at the horse
yeah what do you say come
wow
[Applause]
i guess like you know like you say
compare that's like our super bowl you
know like so my whole life
i was 24 years old i think most of my
whole life like just flash in front of
me you know thinking that
maybe this is why i don't watch this
replay because then i get emotional a
little bit
dude i'm emotional i wasn't even in it i
mean i've done steroids but that's the
closest i've come
i used to do them in high school the
closest i've come today i think watching
the race here with you i
understand why i don't watch that race a
lot i'm sorry man
but it's really exciting i think also
it's a way to kind of channel with just
that that it's even a possibility for
people you know
of course it's inspiring like if there's
young men out there who think about
being jockeys
young latino men out there we have a
good latino audience
um who think about being jockeys or uh
it's interesting or they might have a
kid who's like a more of a petite sized
kid and like what could i get my kid
into
yeah you know you don't think that man
that's really almost the last thing you
think about
probably i feel like it's either hide
and go seek or being a jockey i feel
like if you're kind of more
uh petite size you know um
what uh so take me to through your
journey as like how you got into like
doing like how did it start for
you
yeah well like you say when this race is
kind of like it flashes you know i
thought about myself like you know we're
back at home you know my dad tried to
you know provide better from us you know
like uh
um you know part veracruz
oh i've never been there where is it's
nice it's nice it sounds
nice it's nice you know it's on the
beach right now it had we have a lot
a lot of yeah so but i'm not from
from from the
beach part of the state you know like
i'm more like
to the inside i don't know maybe like
two hours oh you're on the golf side
yeah
yeah oh wow that's interesting right up
in the top
around there that's where i'm from
exactly around there yeah
that's where i'm that's exactly where
i'm from it's a big place
no i mean when i was there it's probably
like you know the town was around
probably
10 000 people oh wow you must be like a
hero huh
oh when i was there you have all my
friends and everything you know
yeah so because 10 000 is pretty small i
mean it's a small town it's a small town
you know it was a very small very poor
town too yeah very very poor you know a
lot of uh
horses like um a lot was horsing like a
big
business there no no no for like uh
that's how it's very crazy that i got
into like you know even from
my town like that and anything around
there
i was the only one doing it because like
i said my dad
um we were like really poor we're very
very poor
so my dad land this job in this farm
and this the the owner of this farm
happened to own a quarter horse
you know and then he saw my dad and my
dad is a little bit smaller than me
oh really probably look at him and be
like oh he could be he could be a jockey
so
he he went and asked my dad hey are you
interested in learning how to become a
joke you know i want you to
like ride my horse and then my dad say
yes
because that's probably like a way uh
for him to do better
morning for us what a rare job too yeah
so
um when i say yes so then i i was like
probably seven years old when i
i was watching my dad becoming a jockey
you know so
i i was like um i love my dad you know
so i was like now i'm gonna be
choose like my dad i wanna be a jockey
and since that early age i was i
i just knew that's exactly what i wanted
to do
your dad must be so proud of you huh
yeah yeah yeah very proud
does he still live there in veracruz or
no yeah my whole family i'm by myself
here me and my wife
and your wife yeah um okay so you your
dad gets into it then you
so how do you get on the horse then well
then um
uh did my dad good was your dad a good
jockey i think so i think my dad was you
i think he was better
than but people wanted to give him
credit you know as a jockey he did it he
did it
um for very short probably like six six
seven years you know
um hey you want to pull your jacket down
in the back it's just right just so you
yeah no you don't take it off you can
leave it on the same pull it down i
think no just on the edges
sorry i can take it off i'm a little bit
hot i was gonna ask you yeah
okay okay i turned the ac down how are
you no that's fine all right that's fine
um yeah it's a cool jacket man what is
that style called
i don't know my wife dressed me yeah she
did she did a good job it almost has
like an authentic like mech
i don't want to say mexican look but
something like that yeah something like
uh
yeah it's like a i don't know what it
reminds me of i just
i haven't seen it in a long time but
it's cool um
okay so you then how do you get on the
horse so so
um so your dad's jockeying is he jocking
in races is he jocking
no yeah and quarter horse races in
mexico very popular quarter horse racing
and
zillow yeah all over mexico is better
bring that up i want to see where that
quarter horse is
and what it's like the little ponies the
little ones no no no big
big horses oh it's four horses it's a
normal sized horse quarter horse but
they're not but it's a very short race
it's like a like you know like one of
those cars that you go like a quarter of
a mile
something like that oh dang so it's like
drag racing and they're more bulk you
know they're yeah yeah sounds like
dragons yeah
and it's a popular event too in mexico
it's very popular in mexico i like in um
all the states in mexico there's a lot
of quarter horse that's how
that that was like uh how it started
when i was 14 i was doing a lot of
quarter horse race in mexico yeah before
i went to mexico city
is it like um what would you compare it
to like a sport here
because uh it's more popular there than
it is here
quarter horse racing probably yeah yeah
i think it's illegal here
oh right no no no no
no i shouldn't say that no it's not
illegal that we have quarter horse race
tracks here but there's not a lot of
them
right well i would say match races much
what
my racing means is like uh in mexico
like anybody that
that has a farm you know could build
their own racetrack and they can put
together a car or like a five six races
you know
right and then uh and then you charge
people to come watch your event and then
that's much racing you know
i think that's i don't think that's that
might not be legal here we'll hear that
yeah because i think a lot of horse like
it's all kind of it might be owned by a
lot of like bigger groups and stuff you
know
something so they don't want like the
smaller guy getting up you know
um okay cool so then you get you start
doing the quarter horse racing and do
you do well at it
yeah i was doing really well that's i
was doing really well by this time
i mean that from when i was seven now
i'm 14 i'm gonna start raising my
uh um quarter horse for my dad and
there's no people calling my dad every
week and every 15 days hey is your kid
available you want him to run
these uh races this day so
my that kind of wasn't in my first agent
so he will like people will call him
okay and then my dad will say hey you
know you we're gonna go raise here and
there you're like my kid's not available
like we wanna we want him to ride a a
bear and you're like that's not we don't
do that
yes horses that will happen so that's
how i got into four years i did it until
i finished my
high school in mexico and in that little
town
and then i asked my dad because now i'm
like
i'm like oh wow like i know i'm good
here like i know i'm good here and
uh by this time i think we were a little
bit better off so i think we finally
were able to put in our farm
a satellite tv and then we used to get
we used to get
espn and then let's do it espn on the
weekends
there will be a now you're wearing
dwayne wade jerseys on the back of the
horse
there will be a show that a half an hour
show we'll talk
specifically about uh the podromo in
mexico
about horse racing in mexico we have we
only have one
one one racetrack official racetrack in
mexico city this is the
in mexico city the hippodrome of the
last americas so there will be 30
minutes
30 minutes of like kind of giving you
the the highlights of the weekend you
know
uh only highlighting the big races so i
will watch that show
every week i will watch the show and i
will see names and i will see like these
top jokies and now
in my head i'm like you know okay i know
i'm good here but am i
like how good am i this is it here yeah
this is it oh that's for that's an old
picture
wow so then you get it in your head can
i go there and do it
yeah so did you go perform how do you
say it again
america that one down a little bit more
down you'll see it like that one no
the one next above no
no that one oh hypodromo
de las americas that's the big place huh
yeah so
it's only in mexico city it's only in
mexico city so so you went there
yeah as soon as i finished my school uh
did you play any other sports in school
or anything i used to play soccer goalie
you know but i was so small yeah
that'd be the craziest yeah who would
put you as the goalie
i know not to say that but we have the
one of the best goalies of mexico jorge
campos you do he was more
he was yeah he was smart wow so maybe
look what do i know man yeah come on
so yeah so um let me see him
yeah see oh he's a legend huh yeah
i want a picture of him in goal
he's a flashy guy i like the colors yeah
he liked the colors oh
that was like i remember when i was
growing up that was a guy everybody
wanted to go
for examples
that's cool right yeah um so yeah okay
so then you get there
so i asked my dad it's like that i
really don't want to go to school
you know i really want to go and you
know challenge myself try it you just
please give me one year
i was i was like i was begging him for
one year opportunity
and then i convinced him i packed my
stuff and i went to mexico city
and yeah was it scary or no it was very
well
it was by like you know when you're so
young and you really want you don't
really think about that you know
i wasn't thinking how was it gonna be
when i was at my
my goal was like i just want to convince
my dad to let me go right
i really want this right so i convinced
him
so the moment that i got in mexico city
i was like
geez okay now what you know that's such
a great statement it's so much when
you're young you don't think about what
it's going to be like when you get there
you just think about what you're
thinking about
yeah and that's one thing it's kind of a
bummer as you get older you start
thinking what is it going to be like
when i
think yeah yeah that's actually i think
that's one of the bummers you know we
started
thinking too much of like you know like
and i think that's probably what
hold us a lot of people to like really
go for what we really want you know
yeah because you're right when you're
young like i just got to get there and
then i'll see what happens yeah you know
okay so you get there and how do you get
into the race has your dad already
agented you
onto a horse or what's going on no that
my dad had my dad stay home you know so
now i'm like you know my like
um even though we're known in our little
town and like the
my region that we were like much racing
you know my dad stays home you know i'll
go by myself to the
to the racetrack
yeah so now i'm going there and then um
like i said i didn't turbo how i was
going to do things you know so
all of a sudden i'm i i i i'm in mexico
city
i want to go to the i want to somehow
ride horses in mexico city
and then i'm like okay well i guess i go
to the
i go to the racetrack right so i go to
the racetrack i'm
like asking people hey how do you get in
the racetrack blah blah you know
oh there is this gate go to this gate so
i'm walking through the gate i have a
garbage bag full of uh some um
um my pictures and things like that to
show people that i'm i'm
like i'm legit i can ride horses right
so and there is a security guard in
there and be like okay
i want to go in he's like where's your
license i'm like well i don't have a
license you know
this is like rudy it's like rudy
rutieres
so uh i'm like well you know like
but i wanna i wanna work how did i do
that he's like oh you first have to get
a license and the guy doesn't give me
any information on how
he never does yeah god damn you know so
now i'm like
he sent me back he doesn't care yeah so
somebody else told me there is like
multiple entries so like
the next day i go try another one same
thing happens they reject me and finally
i learned to
uh to a gate where like the guy is some
were kind of nice yeah and then he told
me no you know what you know like um
come tell them you know that come
tomorrow i'll let you in tomorrow
and then you're gonna go to the stewards
that's the judges you know everybody and
then
just tell them what you want to do and
things like that you know and are there
other guys like you trying to get in
there are you
no no i don't think no i guess everybody
now i know
once i got in you know that how you get
into the racetrack is like you
you there is you have to have somebody
in the racetrack that kind of brings you
in you know like
even if it's like a rider a person that
is an exercise writer you know
or a trainer that can bring you in be
like hey you know i want you to
introduce you today so i want you to be
a jockey or things like that you know
i didn't know anybody there so i i just
so
i go like trick-or-treating
he knew three security guards in two
words i know exactly
exactly so finally i i went into this uh
it's good to know first of all the
security guards are everywhere
that's the best thing to know yeah
that they do their job no matter what
country where it is they're the same guy
yeah exactly okay so you go in so you
finally you get in front of the right
people
yeah well no they weren't even the right
people i went to the judge you know to
the to the stewards
we call them stewards you know the ones
that they regulate and
the the make the rules to apply to the
trainers and everybody
so i went to their office and they're
like okay i hear you wanna you know an
interview with us and i'm like yeah yeah
i wanna be able to
you know to i want a license i wanna
ride horses i wanna know like
and they were like looking at me and i
guess nobody does it my way you know
or the way i was doing it and they're
like oh kid no your super loss is like
you know this is what you have to do
you have to go to each one you know you
have to first try to land a job
let's see whoever employs you you know
to be an exercise
writer or to be you to write a pony to
like you
first you have to have a job you know
once somebody is willing to employ you
then you can come
he's gonna have to sign some papers and
like that's how you're gonna get a
license
so i'm like he's like so i encourage you
to go to each one
and just like knock on the door and see
who who
so then you're going bar in the barn huh
and you found someone i found someone
that the same day i found someone that
that was like okay i'll give you a
chance you know
and then it went well it went well it
went well like i got i got my license i
i had to i thought it went well for me
you know i got to
like exercise right exercise horses in
the morning for him you know
and then and then apple that provide me
somewhere to sleep i
i live i i was living at the mexico uh
city racetrack for like six my first six
months
and do they have like lodging for the
riders and stuff no
where were you guys sleeping over there
i was sleeping on the stall really yeah
on the stove and knowing the stuff is
stable and oh no
really in like hay or something there
was like a little
like camping little mattress that was
there you know like
and was there a lot of guys in there no
no i would choose myself
i guess because i'm coming from a small
town right so everybody's from the city
so i didn't know where i
don't have anywhere else to go dang it's
so wild it's interesting that like
stories from mexico are now like stories
from america like 50 years ago or 70
years ago you know i'm saying it's just
interesting
yeah that's interesting man so that
happened but like quickly
i went there and in 2005 i was able like
to ride my
very first race in mexico city and uh
yeah hippodrome
yeah wow it didn't go well it didn't
yeah
no i've been this last probably by a lot
and did you feel like what happened well
this
i remember the trainer now now i had
changed like different
burns i i think that now now when i was
getting ready to to to finally
debut but do my debut um
the guy had me some pump and he was like
kid you know i'm gonna
when i put you on a horse i'm gonna make
sure at least you finish
top four you know you don't have to
you're gonna finish top four you know
and i was so pumped so finally
you know when i was walking into the
yogis room and i was like was so excited
i was like
doing this and everything i was so
excited you have on 11 rosaries
oh yeah yeah exactly so i'm going to the
race and the guy
the trainer told me you know i don't
want you to do anything i want you to
look down and just push your horse try
to change
whips you know like change you you whip
from the right to left
left to right you know i want you to
look pretty i want people to look at you
and you i want you to look good you know
don't look don't worry about every
anything else you know yeah so i'm i
i'm pumped i'm gonna finish top four so
i'm he's no guarantee
i was gonna win but i'm i'm i'm pumped
right so race goes you know we're coming
down the stretch and i'm like
putting my head down and i start riding
my horse and i'm switching sticks
everything i finally see the wire i'm
gonna stop my horse and
i go i i'm not even kidding you there is
someone
i'm not even kidding you there is some
horses were coming back
[Laughter]
i was like i was so devastated i was
like i wanted to go home i was like oh
maybe i should go right quarter horses
maybe i should just wear it yeah oh my
god
it's so funny just to imagine somebody
um after years of fine print contracts
and getting ripped off by
big wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch
you know you think you're getting grapes
and you're getting damn raisin
that's when i first heard a mint mobile
i was like what is it is it a
you know somebody drives by and just
shoot you know
shoots it shoots a minute in the amount
of something
but when i first heard that mint mobile
is a premium wireless
service that starts it as 15 bucks a
month i thought
what is the catch but after speaking
with mr mint himself
and after using their service it all
made sense there isn't one
mint mobile secret sauce is that they're
the first company to sell wireless
service online only that's right
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs
they get passed on to you so if you're
looking for extra savings mint mobile
offers premium wireless
just 15 bucks a month if you're not a
hundred percent satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money back guarantee
that's right to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month you have
15 bucks don't you
don't you have it check your pants check
your grandparents
and to get that plan shipped to your
door for free go to mint
mobile.com slash theo
that's mint m-o-b-i-l-e dot com
slash t-h-e-o cut your wireless bill
to 15 bucks a month at mint mobile dot
com slash
theo you know you want to kick your
summer off in style with the brand
that's reinventing
men's basics and that's mac welding
they make underwear and i i love them
honestly
they keep my body warm to keep my body
held together
you know as i age my body
starts to distance itself from its from
my skin and my
bones and everything but mac welding
keeps you cool and comfortable all
summer
from working to working out happy hour
to playing with your kid or kids uh
mack weldon has men's essentials for
whatever your day includes
and they really are so they are the best
underwear that i've worn in a long time
and they are mack weldon
they have a swim line with trunks and
board shorts that are quick to dry and
have four-way stretch
fabric they also have a free loyalty
program
called weldon blue level one gets you
shipping for life
for 20 off your first order visit
macweldon.com
t-h-e-o and enter promo code t-h-e-o
that's mac weldon m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n
dot com slash theo promo code theo for
twenty percent off mac
weldon reinventing men's basics
and they do a good job i enjoy
what i wear from them let me think about
another question here okay so then you
get up to so how do you get up to canada
then
and why canada well because i got the
opportunity but then like i said then
it took me a l a while to people to know
me and start giving me the chance but
once people give me the chance in mexico
city
i started doing really good okay so i
started picking it up i'm picking up
this team like right away you know i
finished
uh top apprentice in 2005
and i finished top apprentice in 2016
and i only wrote 2016
like maybe like half of the season 2006
2006 sorry
yeah um um to the mid season because
like on
on on early 2016 somebody from canada
came down to mexico city uh and asking
uh looking
to oh um for an apprentice
and a professional writer okay you know
so somebody said like hey there is guy
um from canada he's looking to
bring some um and he took you up there
yeah he took me up there
was that cool that was really cool well
it was
the whole experience was cool like again
you don't think about what you get how
how is it going to be there right so now
i'm excited i'm like okay
i called my dad i remember i called my
dad and said hey dad what are you
thinking he's like well you're doing
this
this is i don't by this time of that is
like i don't see you ever coming back to
school so
just go go go try to go all the way see
how far you can go right
and is there money are you making money
there in new mexico
and mexico city i was making because
like i said look we're very very poor so
i was making like i thought i was like
now i'm really helping my mom i'm
finally buying
some furniture furnish for the house you
know some cows some new tvs you know
i'm upgrading i'm helping my dad my dad
like now we're like
finally living like you know right we
can buy shoes you know
right you're helping out yeah you're
helping out so um
so yeah and like i said i'm picking up
this team you know so i'm i'm
i'm good right now right so um when this
opportunity came
you know everybody was like you know
what yeah let me encourage you to go my
dad
once my dad told me kind of he was good
like he gave me the
not the okay but kind of like the
reinforcement okay you know like
do the jump i i knew i was going right
so i had to wait for my papers and you
have to ride up there on a horse you fly
up there
no i i flew there my first time in an
airplane too no
so now like it's finally like my day to
go
i remember i was so i was i was always
was like a mama's boy you know
so i remember asking them
to please please come to mexico city and
sleep with me before i was going before
you before i go you know and y'all slept
there
well in my room you know they came and
stayed with me you know they they
oh yeah to wish you off right yeah yeah
and do you have siblings too or no
i have i have three three siblings i
want i have a younger brother and
a two older sisters and do they ride or
no no no nobody writes
is it a female sport as well or no yeah
of course no no it's female we have
joking uh
female jockeys here in in in um
california and everywhere every all day
and mexico know much
but now my my brother now became an
agent a jockey agent
and yeah there is probably seven growth
being
jockeys in mexico city is he your agent
yet your brother no
okay no no he has to improve a lot
[Laughter]
dude put nick on a horse or put me on a
rehab dude
um so yeah that's how i ended up in
canada
with no money i took i know i think i
took like
ten thousand pesos and my goal was like
with this ten thousand pesos
i'm uh i'm gonna exchange for canadian
money
and then i i i'm supposed to have an
agent i supposed to have a place to stay
and i supposed to have a car
how to travel around right this is what
they offered me this is what they told
me
about 500 bucks yet yeah but when i got
there i
i i i exchanged all my money i think i
got like 400 450 back in the day you
know something like that i don't know
but
less no more than 400. so
um there is like no agent there is no
place to stay so they go
and they put me in this hotel very close
to the racetrack
now i know it's very close i didn't even
know where the ratio was back back in
those days you know
i had to pay for my own hotel right so i
stayed there three nights
and all my money they basically i just
spent my money
in the hotel and then like um
i had no food i don't speak english i
basically was living like on chips from
a vending machine
somehow i knew what a vending machine
was what kind of chips was it you
remember
potato chips and like some other type of
chips i don't know
i was drinking water i do freeze if i do
a vending machine i do fritos
i don't even think fritos were in canada
back in those days they might not have
been
you know what you could be right about
so i was starving for three days
you couldn't but that helps your weight
dude so you get on i'm pretty sure i got
super light you know
yeah yeah so i was like you guys show up
at nine pounds
ten ounces on a horse exactly this is
really funny because finally
my agent shows up and now he's taking me
to the racetrack right
oh that's exactly what now this is a
typical agent that's just like hollywood
they show up
just when it's time for you to try and
make some money okay yeah so he took me
to the racetrack
and then um he showed me the racetrack
and when i look at the racetrack i was
like
i'm used to mexico city run right
in a mile racetrack you know milo this
racetrack is five footlands
it's like compared to a mile strike now
you were like in a very tiny circle
and i was like oh this is a restaurant
like
jesus what am i doing here you know and
i was like okay
i and right then in my head i made my
plan i was like no i'm gonna ride one
week
if i win whatever i win buy my ticket
i'm going back i'm out of here i'm not
gonna stay here you know so that's what
happened i rode there
the first week i won like four races
something like that you know
and then i must i couldn't wait for like
payday right
and then i was like okay where's the
check so they come with the news and be
like no we pay here every
every 15 every two weeks oh so i'm like
oh god damn it i had to stay
no there will be another night okay
i i i'll wait another week i wait
another week
win another four races i don't know how
many races i want but i know when they
check him
it says like around like sixteen
thousand fifteen thousand something like
that wow
and then the first thing i did is like
go to the calculator how many pesos are
these things you know
and it was a lot of pesos and i was like
i'm gonna stay here
i'm gonna stay here this is not too bad
that's crazy man and so you stayed in
canada for how long
i stay in canada all the way up to 2011.
that's cool i love canada man so nice
he's in vancouver too vancouver
oh yeah vancouver's cool man kitts beach
or something is that out there
it's a different it's not it's not it's
not that's not the name of the
saint kitts or something is there a kids
i should know i i lived there like uh
yeah you probably yeah i should have
known but i'm hoping
you go to the beach there sometime like
they have like rocks and like
i love canada yeah yeah and the people
are people are super nice
people are super nice people are so nice
in canada man i don't know how they did
it
now they can't solve this cove i think
canada is still closed from covent
has mexico been closed for covington i
don't think they never really close
i don't think they never really closed
america it's the biggest bunch of bull i
feel like it's such the biggest
i used to have those stocks when
discovered began you know because i was
like i
think everybody was really following a
lot and i was following a lot what's
happening in mexico and i hear like the
new president talk and
how he was like you know um his
explanation for these buyers and
everything like that and
and there's his reason why he wouldn't
close the borders and yeah
people would be some restriction but he
would not close the borders you know
and then i was like why can't united
state do this and not
even my wife was like you know this
president doesn't know what he's doing
you know he's gonna like
because the health care system in mexico
is not not the same
it's not the same as here right so i was
like well we'll see we choose we'll see
right and and it's fine it's fine
unbelievable
it's unbelievable man you can even see
it here like you look florida you look
texas you look
yeah or even even even california you
know like how many
uh um you know we went like super crazy
shot everything down now that everything
is going back to normal
you know um everything's fine everything
is fine you know so yeah it's weird
everything's just suddenly back and
everything yeah it's like nothing really
changed right like even in our job now
like going into
delmar season in san diego now they're
it seems that it's gonna it's nice but
now for us in this regard into covet
it's almost like that now they they say
they're not forcing us
to get the vaccine but they really are
because now is like uh if i want to go
and do my normal training in the
mornings
i have to be vaccinated oh yeah
otherwise
i'm not going to be allowed to go in the
mornings and train i'm going to be
allowed to race
but i need to be in a separate room and
to me
look i'm not educated or highly educated
or anything but to me it's like
we all the same family we're riding here
in santa anita nobody's getting tested
what's different for right now
why it's gonna has to be so strict in
delmar than what it is right now
so but now it does those are the rules
and we need to apply to the rules and
it's the same thing this guy cole
beasley who plays for i think buffalo
now
um he just said the same thing that he's
a lot he's a wide receiver
for nfl for american football and he has
to
uh he doesn't want to get vaccinated but
now he has to like practice
separate it's just ridiculous like what
he can play but he's still allowed to
play in the game
i know it's just crazy it's like right
now right now
i'm allowed to go in the mornings do my
and we're not testing
you know we're just we still we're not
doing anything
you know you know even the restaurants
you know why why can't you just if
everything is open now i think they're
going to have a little bit of
restrictions
i don't know well it's just it's also
crazy like the mask man is lifted in la
right
also in tennessee but if you're on an
airplane you have to have a mask on in
between
it's like for what and also the whole
time like so i've been living in
tennessee a lot during the pandemic
and like everyone in florida isn't dead
everyone in tennessee actually has been
having a great time
and it's just i don't know it doesn't
really make any sense you could say
whatever you want about the science but
even the
if you test the science in reality which
is how you create science
um with hypothesis certainly huge cities
not getting sick yeah has to be a valid
test
yeah no definitely but it's amazing that
mexico didn't even shut down i knew that
i knew they didn't i couldn't get it to
myself like i've been
in mexico i've been to like there were
some frustrations but there was like but
you were allowed you were still allowed
to go to
um to cross the border and go and i'm
sure there's still restaurants and
things like that you know yeah
people and even lighting i was thinking
i've been afraid a couple times like
i'm like you telling me that they
wandered through africa and got masks on
everyone in africa you're out of your
mind yeah it just all seemed kind of
crazy um
let's get into a couple more questions
we have one right here that came in from
these two
well here we go right here what are
these called these uh
uh track rack track tricks
i don't know what you call them track
rats beautiful ladies i'm going to call
them
heydio hey mario we just had a quick
question we're from louisville
and we're just trying to figure out
where all the rich horse trainers and
owners
hang out at oh dad they came out
bars or restaurants or golf courses that
we should start going to
and thea will see you september 18th to
celebrate
my best friend's 21st birthday in
cincinnati
oh congratulations yeah that's insane
gang that the cincinnati show is going
to be great man
uh yeah i guess these ladies are looking
to meet some of the owners
they had to somehow manage to get into
swedes and ready
yeah no like i said the people that own
the horses
um they're like they're you know like
a different level you know so yeah
actually but now there is like a
something called popular they're doing
like these syndicates you know like when
there is like
a group of people a group of people
there is a guys there is a couple guys
they're doing it
here in santa anita too where like
there's two guys they get a bunch of
people chipping a little bit of money
and then they they're on like small
pieces of a horse you know
and then oh interesting could theo just
like
buy a horse that is i think he can
afford a horse but but that's already
i don't know about that i'll tell you
this if i can i'll tell you what horse
it is it's named tom thumb and i met him
one time at the pasadena fair and it's
the world you get to name your horse
whatever you want well actually you
choose how to you have to uh
yeah what is it like there is we have
some type of
oh you have to send the name send the
name to a company and then they will
give you the okay
but there is a bunch of little tricks
that you can you can do so
but could theo just buy one that's
already like trained and ready to go
and then have you as yes rider yeah that
is different that's
that's they say does it really
complicate to explain that because we
have like
all type of races like in a whole car if
i can show you up you know we have
what it calls claiming racing okay yeah
and then i think the lowest we have here
in santa anita um is like 20
this is the horse i'm at right here and
that's tom thumb
you see him right there he is so tiny
you may want to take him home
four-legged superhero right there so
everyone can meet the world
how long are you going to be here today
for maybe he's going to
he'll be here all day how small
um so so someone can buy say how does
someone get in a claiming race what is
that oh
but that's kind of like the low level
level races you know horses they cannot
compete in a lounge race you know
they're like
they're a little bit lesser you know
that you you try to put them where they
can
win you know so you okay you don't want
to break the horse hard you know so you
kind of
had to first find where his level at and
then raise them there so he can be
competitive you know
so there is i think it's 20 some
thousand dollars the cheapest we have
here maybe maybe a little bit cheaper
and then uh so
you choose contact you trainer or a
trainer there and say hey i'm so-and-so
and i want to claim a horse and you
can't claim that horse
and put him in the race well you had to
do this you had to do that while he's
racing
oh so so after the race right
it's yours no if you put the claim in
before
before he's going to race right so
now if the claimant goes through that
means the horse nothing happens to the
horse the horse
clears the veterinarian and everything
because they want to make sure that the
new owner gets
a sound horse you know okay so because
you already put the clam and the horse
came back from the race good now
you won't you're just yourself really
you just pick him up that's it you just
pick him up and
and call your trainer and then and get
him going huh get him going
that's how you do it that's what i said
you can own a horse we could do it we
have room here i think maybe
i would name it i have one horse
actually brendan that we keep back here
sometimes but
um that's a different show he eats
kratom and nicotine yeah
definitely he's on a unique diet
what are the fitness things that you do
fitness-wise to stay in shape man i
train boxing
you do yeah yeah i train boxing just
because that's the
that's what i love right and then uh
that's the only thing that i can i'm
actually excited to go and do
you know i try doing the normal uh
training you know the cardio and
weights and these things but it's just
like it it's not exciting it's not
exciting for me you know but
i go boxing and gets me the cardio it
gives me the strength or
something and are there other exercises
that they ask that that help you be a
jockey or is it just about kind of
keeping your weight down keeping your
weight down you have well we gotta we
we write like i said we train a lot of
horses during the week so that
kind of we get our fitness somehow from
there too like
um we can do some type of a lot of
squats you know a lot of leg work you
know
our legs need to be strong our core our
arms because the position you're in can
you bring that up nick do you mind just
hit when he's on a horse
yeah because you're real i mean you're
in there the goal is to stay as small as
possible yeah i
did not make them yeah and is there a
certain like a
new like a nucleus point on the horse
you want to stay
on top of kind of in the center yeah
okay
wow man and some
do do can now can a little person like
or they used to call but a little
person can they be a jockey or no
they could they i didn't i think that
would be difficult because the arm
length you know it probably
okay so you have to have more so the arm
length is a little bit limited yeah or
maybe they wouldn't be as
strong as you know the push would be
like yeah i'm just curious as if
why that why why wouldn't more men or
women like that be
a b b jockeys and what about a child
anybody ever try to sneak a child in
there can a child do it no no you had to
be
i think you had to be 16 i think is
probably the
youngest you can understand probably 18
but you have to be signed by your
parents
and so does the horse getting that guy
he's gonna
who's gonna do it yeah
dude yeah he could do it man i would
like to see him do it huh i think that
would be dangerous
we need to send him down to the hippo uh
hippodrome
yeah mexico yeah yeah we need to send
him down to mexico city managed to see
what happens to him
um do you so the horse gets excited when
it wins does it know you feel like the
horse knows that it won't oh yeah i
think so
i'm not gonna tell you every horses you
know but yeah they know they know where
they win they even get they probably you
know because they have a groom right the
groom is the one that
they probably spend the most amount of
time with a groom you know every
single day from super early to super
late in the afternoon you know so
i mean these grooms love these
horses right so if if if their horse win
you know they probably get the extra
carry
the extra so they really know everything
everything
bobbing for apples whatever they want
yeah wow
i'm trying to think of some other
questions that we had nick did anything
pop in your head or anything good come
in here's a question from a beautiful
young lady obviously and this is
from the dust bowl era um this question
and that's just a joke ladies are
beautiful kids and that one kid looks a
little bit like i'm going to say it like
hezbollah who just sent in
uh
what's up and mario we are from
saskatoon saskatchewan in canada
and we have a question from mario our
race track in town is closing down and
they are opening a new one
outside of town the first nation people
are going to open it up
and i was just wondering if you have any
superstitions
riding on an old track that's tried and
true versus riding on a brand new track
gang gang gang gang oh that's it
that's so good superstitions yeah i
think we all have little superstitions
you know
yeah yeah uh one of my name first like
let's say like we have big days of
racing big days when like when like
they're expensive races you know
and if whatever i'm wearing if i'm have
a
if i don't have a good day you know i
never wear that
um for a big day uh oh okay
yeah but i think we all have a little
superstition is there more superstitions
you think between latino riders
or uh or any other type of writers do
you notice one or the other really or no
no but i i really think if everything
everybody will have a little bit of
something you know like
even if it's settled you know like just
you don't do this type of thing before
you're going to race you know there is
some people there is a very common
thing to say to owners or or trainers
to to say hey i see you in the winter
circle and some people
hate hate okay so they won't say certain
things
jinx themselves themselves and things
like that you know um
do you uh is there will you wear socks
and stuff during a thing like do you
wear what do you wear to keep yourself
as light as possible
well our equipment is super light uh
what i didn't yeah i mean this weighs
probably all this total probably weighs
three pounds so probably like our pants
socks beds and undershirts
alone is probably like only two pounds
less than two pounds
you know and will you eat that morning
or you usually will kind of just have
something lighter i have something light
at you because you don't like you don't
want to go right with your belly full
you know like i have a coffee and i have
like you know like a piece of bread or
things like that you know
okay that one is an accident yeah so i
was gonna ask
mario have you had bad accidents i just
saw this on your instagram you were
sending a message to your fans telling
them you were okay back in september
2020.
yeah back in september i think that was
a very hard one i got a good concussion
out of
out of that one you know so i landed on
my head
it just landed and i didn't move i got
scared because i never landed that way
and then um what is it like um
i just felt a pain that i didn't feel
before and i was like oh my god i'm as
good as gone
that's exactly what i thought but then i
was gonna be in the wheelchair you can
do the chariot races yeah
exactly unfortunately we have a lot of
fellow jokers that
you know they get hurt they get hurt
like that and then that happened we
will share and so what happens what is
the number one accident that happens
with uh with horses and with uh with
racing is it
that the horse stops and you fly off is
that you get knocked off is it the
trampoline like what's the top deal
that really gets you hampered out it's
like for example
um you can get trapped like a my last
fall
i have a little clips you know there is
like inexperienced writers
but not an expert right somebody
sometimes a rider can be a little bit
careless you know
get too involved in the race and start
shifting you know and then you get
you get sandwiched in between horses and
you now your horse
uh clip hills you know trips and with
other horse legs and then
i think that's the scariest part you
know and then sometimes so that would be
the scariest thing
yeah that would be the scariest thing
you know because then like there is
nothing in your control you know that is
like
you choose waiting i remember back in
when that happened
i was i i can see the guy shifting but
he was shifting a lot and i'm like okay
he's gonna realize he's doing this a lot
and then so i kept riding my horse right
i can because i had a hole to go through
i kept writing kept writing he kept
going and by the time i'm like it
realized okay he is not gonna
he's not gonna stop right another horse
was coming way faster
in my outside and that's how the
sandwich happened and by that time it
was too late for me to do anything and
i just tried to hold as hard as i could
my horse trip and
i went flying and is it uh
where where can the horse see when it's
running what can it say well horses go
like they can see
like uh to to their side but the hor the
eyes are like a little bit on the side
so they they
they're aware of horses coming behind
you know
they can look backwards that though and
is it only man horses that run or female
horses
really only female only female horses
you can write them
like you can mix each other you know you
can but that's not very common
but phillies run with the phillies um
mel's one with the males but
we don't we don't um we have equality on
the sport so a female
can run with the guys so like in the
kentucky derby move this a little closer
come on
in the kentucky derby like is it man in
that race is it male horses or female
horses or it's both
i don't know you gotta get out of here
is both is both uh
um i think one female um horse won the
kentucky derby wow yeah i don't remember
what the name
of the horse but yeah a female is not
very common
you know but like you know they can run
there's no restrictions whatsoever
for a female horse not to enter that you
just have to
qualify if you good enough to qualify
you can you can run so
more more commonly a lot of the horses
that you ride are male horses
i know both yeah do you notice a
difference in the horses oh yeah yeah
oh yeah the girls are more feisty you
have to treat them differently
you have to treat them differently
oh they're so gotta take them to the
movies oh you have to be so unkind and
nice to them
and open the door
wow i have a lot of language feelings
with female horses
really a lot of what phillies luck you
know but they do run really well for me
really yeah maybe they like you huh yes
okay
yeah i can see it man yeah handsome guy
i could see it
winning colors genuine risk and regret
yeah the only phillies to win the
kentucky derby it doesn't look like any
female jockeys have won
no no no no they haven't won one i don't
think there's a female joke
nick did you have something else that
kind of popped up uh just with like
uh the gambling like how
there's always such a heavy favorite
where are they getting that information
from what is that based off of if
because the horses don't
have a ton of history behind them from
what i understand they race for like a
year or two
so like how do they know who's the
favorite and
yeah you know they did we had like they
have the past performances
you know you you can see for example um
or
they they um we they record the workouts
as well you know so if a horse is
working in
good times you know uh so that tends to
be the
oh how they doing it you know there's
cameras female them in the mornings how
they're working and things like that you
know
and is all that available to the public
if you want a research yeah yeah that's
available you buy it perhaps dude
there is people only there is like the
the the hardcore
handicappers the hard core gamblers you
know
they you go you buy this book and you
study this book and
you can see the past performance what
they have all kinds of descriptions
whether the horse did
if he got in any kind of trouble he
broke leg from the
gate oh that has all kinds of things you
know dang
speed figures and all these type of
things it goes too crazy
and can a horse spit do they spit what i
don't think so no i don't think those
are like
llamas i think yeah right yeah yeah
you're right
could you see yourself venturing out and
getting on the back of a different
animal you ever think about it
oh it's just like make a like like a so
it's not
like as time goes on maybe when you know
when when the horse and days are over
maybe getting on uh
what's the one sometimes they put kids
on the thing the little uh
oh yeah no no i think one sleep or
something yeah
once i retire once i retire
i i think i'm gonna choose to stay like
you know
focus on my family because like who's
raising the only like
different about that is like we are
all year round no no breaks no breaks
for us you know
and no breaks it's not that you can't
take up you you i can't i can say you
know what i want to take a month off
but the the thing is that like i cannot
afford to do that because if you're
doing good
you need to keep that business you need
to keep that business because the moment
you're gone
there's somebody else that is gonna be
riding those horses it's like podcasting
man in some ways i think it's like any
business you know you want to stick it
with it while you can yeah and if i and
if you're doing
bad then you have to stay there every
day to
to somehow right to get better to get
better right now to get some
and that's that's i probably put my kid
in that yeah be fun huh
could you imagine how fun that is if
you're a kid because you're probably not
going to get that hurt
yeah and you're just the crowd loves it
when you
when those kids come out that'll
probably be really fun
um i could do that i could see myself
doing that it looks so
warm too so fluffy
yeah um that looks like brendan's kid a
little bit doesn't it
it really does um here's a question
right here from a young man i believe
he's sent in a question before i feel
like this fella i've seen him but it's
nice to see him again
what's up theo it's my birthday so i
wanted to send a little question for
your little equine piggyback
fella you got there when i went to a
horse race i did a little bet
so i was wondering if maybe the jockeys
got in on that and maybe
talking to the friend hey i'm gonna beat
you i bet you 10 bucks
or maybe you know maybe they just talk
all the time when they're up there
on it in them horses
so thanks thank you brother happy
birthday man that's a good question
is there any is there any greg
williamson going on there's any cross
betting amongst the group you guys do
any
no we don't cross bed but we're like
like we're so competitive with each
other because that's the only other
thing like
us joking we're freelances we don't make
money we don't really like if you really
want to make
good money you have to be able to you
have to be winning really
you have yeah that's the only time you
know that's the only time you really
make money you know winning you know
like say if i ride five horses in a week
and i finish last and all of them
i'll probably get yeah what do they get
600 bucks
okay so you get a small amount for
racing and if you win
then you get percentage of the purse
like say kentucky derby so that horse
won
yeah i get 10 of whatever that horse
made okay what did that horse make let's
look it up
maybe like one point 1.6 million
so you get 160 000 or whatever you get
at 10 and now is that on
any any race you win
wow interesting yeah that's really cool
man
so wow so it's really on you you got to
get out there and do it huh
yeah yeah you have to get so yeah so to
that's that
uh that question yeah there is like like
because there's a lot of competition
between us riders you know i can be like
you 10 bucks i beat you in this race you
know that type of thing right is there
some
are there some riders that are just like
all ego and just maniacs oh yeah yeah
yeah
there is a lot of fights and there is
all kinds of you know like if somebody
cuts you off and from like you know
we have fights we have all kinds this is
hilarious hilarious dude
he's really hilarious what's up purse so
the derby is 1.8 million so that's a
huge payday but what's it like a right
you're doing these horses
races weekly what are the person
regularly barriers is like from like uh
i think 25 000 dollar plus here is the
lowest one
and then it goes up to in a norm on a
regular day it goes to like you know
sixty five thousand dollars seven
thousand dollars and so if you have four
races today
right say you have four races today and
if the average race is a forty thousand
dollar race for the day
so if you won all four of them then you
could make forty thousand then
right is that right no no four thousand
times sixteen you can make around
sixteen thousand
or something like that that's great wow
that's cool man
yeah and does all their money come from
the betting
yeah the racetrack i think the betting
the racetrack puts up that uh
that money you know the racetrack puts
the first money you know and
so no actually it doesn't come from the
the the racer keeps all the
all the money all the betting money yeah
the racer does put the burst yeah but uh
the birds don't necessarily come from
from the beddings because otherwise
we'll get a percent of betting it will
be probably much better for
get that pay-per-view money then yeah
yeah um so then where you guys money
comes from what the entry phase you
think or something
who knows some i really don't know that
part of it
but somehow the racer puts up that money
i i think i think it's
a share of the gambling it's not all the
gambling money is the purse
but they probably take apart from there
you know but like i said but we don't
they don't share
that right they're not sharing all of it
yeah yeah they never are dude
so they never are people paying for
parking you ain't getting a share of
that there's a lot of things
you ain't getting to share that
enchilada yeah there's a lot of things
you're not getting a share of
yeah so wow mario i'm just trying to
think of any other thing that really
anything bro
so now when would you switch hands with
the whip does that matter
yeah sometimes yeah uh it matters
because some horses like it better you
know or sometimes when
you know the horse is still trying but
you need that little extra push you know
you
all of a sudden touch them from there
from the other side they get a little
they're like
a little uh extra extra kick extra push
you know like so all those little like
type but now we go into like super
little details you know that yeah little
details matter you know
sometimes if you move a little bit too
early you won't you're not gonna be able
to get there or you get there
too too late or or you move too soon and
then somebody
you don't get that enough at the same
time
it's so interesting because a car like a
race car you're in
you have you you have an amount of gas
that you know everything is so
finite yes but with a horse it's like
kind of
you don't really know so there's this
but but that's our job that's why we
have to know right now
unfortunately yeah we don't know if we
don't have an uh if the horse they give
us all mid race
yeah there's nothing we can do but
sometimes that happens sometimes you
just get on a horse mid-race yeah
no yes or you don't sometimes you don't
work with the horses in advance yeah no
sometimes you don't you sometimes you
choose get
uh you you that day you just writing
that oh you somebody put you in a horse
that you never read in that you never
have even training you know
so now it's our job to like try to
figure it out
in 10 minutes you know what that horse
is like you know or even through the
race you know try
try to um um manage to see
okay how is this horse am i still having
something and he still horse is this
horse still have something he's gonna
have something for the end
all of that you know we have to be able
to to tell you know
[Music]
did you uh when you chose your wife did
was she
did you choose a smaller woman because
you want to make another jockey kind of
no
my wife is still she is actually all my
oldest they're tall yeah my all my
girlfriends i don't think i ever have a
a uh had a a girlfriend
like us same same children or the same
height as me yeah i like that i like
it i like girl i like big girls taller
though
yeah yeah yeah yeah big difference hey
whatever
english yeah uh any other good questions
that came in nick from
videos you said it's when your body
tells you how you feel and how long do
you plan on going
i'm personally my goal is just to do
this another six years you know 40 yeah
to 40 and that's that's it like you said
you sacrificed a lot you know
like you always travelling and like my
wife
like you know there we have it's very
hard
to make friends you know because like
friends usually do things on the weekend
on the weekend when i'm i'm writing
right so even if my wife hey let's make
plans like it's all
that i'm like i'm never available for
those type of things even for my
for my uh kid you know like there i can
be
choose a part of the community of his
school or i'm not available for those
things you know so it's a lot
this is the type of things that like i
know i'm sacrificing right now
that's why i'm gonna i want to try to
give my all by the time i reach 40 i
want to be able to have something where
i can
lay back and be able to live of that and
just be with my family
yeah how often do you get to so you live
here in los angeles
in los angeles okay how often do you get
to be at home then
right now mostly with santa anita yeah
most of in santa anita but then like i
said we go
to um to um san diego then back to
orange county there is another race
track in orange county yeah
uh but this is local so locally we're
moving a lot right
but then uh before let's say before
covet you know like
i ride for this guy that owns a lot of
horses so usually he gets
good horses when you get a good horse
you don't necessarily compete
just here at santanita if there is a big
race in louisiana or kentucky or new
york miami you know
you travel to this to these places you
know so
there's a lot of traveling going on you
know that's cool man is there one place
that's not the is that like the the
is it fun to race in louisiana is it fun
to race in miami is like the place
that's really kind of cool to race miami
seems like real beautifully yeah
miami is cool like uh i like going to
dubai
dubai is good dubai yeah wow really
yeah dubai is cool what is it about it
it's like too extravagant you know like
it's like rich
people eating gold she basically yeah
the racetrack is like
eating other people i think it goes like
2 billion to beat the racetrack there is
a
there is like the hotel you can watch
the race oh it's
just beautiful it's fancy huh and a lot
of money too
that's crazy sometimes it's crazy to me
how much money some people have
i know me too isn't it crazy what are
they gonna do with it i mean you're not
gonna live eternally
yeah it seems so crazy and then you
would see other people be poor
it just is crazy to me sometimes yeah
but
i don't think you really realize when
you like i remember
i was very poor you know like i mean you
were struggling you know
a lot but all the way up to maybe
12 13 years old like that never really
occurred to me i was happy i was
laughing i know my mom loved me
yeah it's just my dad love us you know
like yeah we know that we didn't
because you were aware of things that
you don't have you know we didn't have
tv with you
but like that wasn't like uh something
for to be asked to be depressed about i
think the older you get you know
even now you know like sometimes i feel
guilt oh i feel that i try to think
about my parents because now i'm a
parent you know my kid then
we're going to you know to the store or
we're going to this i'm like
i want that i want this and for me to be
able to provide for him and kind of like
whatever he wants i buy him you know
and then to think geez you know what
like i remember me
as a kid when i was a kid asking for
things but
i i never i never got any yeah you know
i never got any i i
now i go back and be like you know how
hard but you know i will feel right now
if my kid is asking me for
something and i it's just like it will
break your heart you know so
i give it to my dad for that you know i
mean that that probably was probably one
of the hardest part for a parent to be
able to
give something that a kid is asking for
you know
oh yeah i bet man yeah i remember some
of the gifts we would get even growing
up were just like regular
i remember my mom gave us something one
time that we already had at home she
just wrapped it up oh really
listen to me this is ours
i have a little bit of a sad story funny
story i
i tell people sometimes now um
i always used to write to santa freaking
santa never
never like never got me anything right
so i probably was around like eight
years old
and i uh um i was writing to santa
and i don't know what i was asking for
but i know i know he didn't
give me what i asked for and then but
i remember riding put in the car um and
then the next day woke up and a present
was there so i was like
holy it worked like
he didn't forget me this year you know
so i'm all excited i go
unwrap the present and i remember i had
like this little soldier
you know and i think i asked for a
remote control car or something like
that
and i was so mad i was so pissed off i
was like you know this is
how can you get it wrong and i was like
unbelievable you never came and
when you came you give me the wrong
thing you didn't even you didn't even
give me what i asked for you know and i
was like
making this huge tantrum and i didn't
talk anything about it you know
until now that i'm an adult i'd be like
you know like my dad probably
bought his ass to be able to provide
that day and
for me to be able to that kind of brush
my heart a little bit when i think about
that
yeah it's hard to fit it's hard
sometimes it's weird to think how kit
like
what parents want for their and then how
kids sometimes are just unappreciative
but there's nothing you can do you're
just a kid you don't know anything yeah
you don't know
yeah when you're a kid you don't know
anybody you know and sometimes it's like
a clue
my mom would give us a shoulder be like
hey you should join the military
yeah um i think man dude mario thank you
so much man
i really appreciate it dude i really
appreciate you coming in and just
talking to us it's so
interesting just to think about what's
going on now and now when i watch the
race i'm gonna have such kind of a
different inkling
is there any point my last question is
there any point in the race where you
would stand up on the horse or no
the goal is just oh no yeah like if you
like if you kind of
sense something like wrong with the
horse you know like all of a sudden you
feel funny steps on the horse like
yeah you you pull up that horse you know
like you don't wanna
like you try to like i say this is this
is our partners you know like i
horses give me everything i have you
know horses took me from property
sent me to canada give me a good point
give me give me my i i
got my wife got my child beautiful home
now that i own so all through horses all
through horses you know so i have an
amazing amount of love for them so every
time that i i feel you know something is
just not right
you know i'll stop the horse you know
i'll stop the horse because you know
like i say that's
i'm so grateful and thankful that uh
like i'm able to do what i do you know
yeah wow that's so interesting man one
day you were gonna have you had to come
if you're not to the racetrack you'll
have to come to the farm where my my
wife have that
yeah can i go one time yeah of course
dude i would love that man
you'll have a lot of fun i would love to
go get on a horse that'd be freaking
crazy we should come to uh
i don't know if san diego is gonna i
think san diego is gonna have
open open full crowd you should come to
opening del mar del mar
when is it do you know it's a july 16.
opening day you should come to opening
day in del mar
i can maybe make that salad you you like
it a lot of del mar is cool too not a
pretty ladies
is there oh a lot oh i'll take it tamar
is beautiful
yeah lamar's a beautiful area most of
the girls are drunk before the first
race
that's a neutral note yeah as long as
the whole as long as
long as the horses are sober yeah
they're they're going to be sober
nothing gets what matters yeah you
should definitely
do yeah we'll swap information man i'd
love to come to one that'd be cool
thank you a lot thank you for having me
i was like i couldn't believe it i was
so
i was when you guys reached out i was
like i can't i was like like i say like
a little groupie
oh that's cool well yeah and thank
walker bueller man he's the one who was
telling me he was we're just talking
about jockeys the other day
and uh and i was like yeah we gotta have
a jockey and thank you nick
nick reached out and connected with you
so mario gutierrez man thank you so much
for coming in man thank you thank you
yeah good luck in the races
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
in my bones but it's gonna take
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
just
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these wells that i've been robbing
they want something